[BELL RINGS]
♪ Oh, Helpters.
-Yes? ♪
♪ Can you help me by chance? ♪
♪ You see I've got this big hat
I like to wear when I dance. ♪
♪ That's a really big hat.
- Why thank you, Primm. ♪
♪ But from the moment that
I move, all my troubles begin. ♪
♪ We've got a word for troubles,
and the word is "bugs." ♪
♪ They're the pesky, little
problems that nobody loves. ♪
♪ We can debug
if you tell us more. ♪
♪ I think I'll show you
on the dance floor. ♪
♪ I've got a big hat.
I've got a big dance. ♪
♪ Gotta move my head,
gotta move my hands. ♪
♪ Do it! ♪
♪
♪ Oh, no! ♪
♪ Helpsters.
- Yes. ♪
♪ Did everybody see that? ♪
♪ Every time I do my dance,
I'm always losing my hat. ♪
♪ A hat that won't stay,
there's a problem for sure. ♪
♪ Can anybody think of something
that will keep it secure? ♪
♪ Tape it!
- Huh? ♪
♪ That's what I said. ♪
♪ Tape it on, just attach it
right onto your head. ♪
♪ Here's a little piece of tape
from the kitchen drawer. ♪
♪ Now we'll see you
on the dance floor. ♪
♪ I've got a big hat,
I've got a big dance. ♪
♪ Gotta move my head,
gotta move my hands. ♪
♪ Do it!
Do it! ♪
♪
♪ Ah, the tape
wasn't strong enough! ♪
♪ Strap it.
- Huh? ♪
♪ Strap it to your chin. ♪
♪ We'll get a strap
from the strap box ♪
♪ and sew it right in. ♪
♪ The hats are all debugged,
they can't fall anymore. ♪
♪ So we'll see you
on the dance floor. ♪
♪ We've got big hats.
We've got a big dance. ♪
♪ Gotta move our heads,
gotta move our hands. ♪
♪ Do it! ♪
♪ Yeah, we do. ♪
♪ Getting down now.
- Do it! ♪
♪
♪ Woo! Hello!
- Come on! ♪
♪ Helpsters! ♪
♪